on va se refaire une petite vidéo un peu
à l'ancienne comme ça on se pose sur une
table en garde des choses - des éléments
est ce que je prendrais pas une fan je
vais prendre une feuille parce qu'avec
une faille c'est toujours mieux le but
aujourd'hui c'est de venir analyser ce
qui se passe du côté de chez au nord et
regarder si c'est intéressant d'acheter
ce truc là là le honor madjid 4
professional edition alors là j'ai la
version lite aux normes hadji 4 light
c'est pas le sujet c'est histoire de
vous remettre un peu dans le contexte
d'autres smartphones de honor j'en ai
déjà parlé juste d'ailleurs déjà montré
toute la partie vidéo de ce smartphone
mais on va reparler dans quelques
instants donc voilà je vais vraiment
qu'on se dise ok au nord c'est une
marque qui avait un peu perdu sa superbe
à cause de la perte des services google
on a déjà beaucoup parlé on en parle un
peu aujourd'hui parce qu'il revienne et
puis que petit à petit on en parlera
plus du tout parce qu'ils les ont
récupérés ils font séparer de huawei
c'est une nouvelle histoire qui s'écrit
aujourd'hui on se rappelle aussi que
dans toute cette histoire est bien avant
au nord c'était la marque jeune de
huawei donc on n'avait pas des
smartphones aussi haut de gamme qu'on
peut retrouver aujourd'hui avec ceux aux
normes a dû quatre pros avant d'aller
pouvoir retrouver à plein de produits
très cool mais on n'allait pas aussi
loin on avait des produits mais pour
l'asie honore magic 4 sono magic 4e
magic3 mais qu'on n'aurait pas eu en
france donc voilà ça c'est une toute
nouvelle histoire qui s'écrit chez nous
et c'est intéressant alors je veux qu'on
se dise ok ok ok donc on considère que
au nord c'est un outsider c'est une
marque qui revient qui a une histoire
certes mais qui revient est ce que je
dois venir me positionner sur cette
marque aujourd'hui qui vient faire un
peu les mêmes promesses qu'on va
retrouver avec un samsung avec un apple
avec tous les grosses marques du marché
à xiaot me avec les smartphones très
haut de gamme avec le haut du panier il
arrive avec un smartphone dans le haut
du panier et c'est là où le marqueur va
nous servir à quelque chose regardez on
est quand même à 1099 euros 1099 euros
pour une configuration 8 plus de 156
donc c'est pas n'importe quoi c'est cher
donc moi je me dis est ce que j'ai envie
de mettre quasiment 1100 euros sur la
outsider ou est-ce que je pars sur des
valeurs refuges de smartphones que sont
notamment samsung et apple c'est
vraiment la question à se poser c'est
vraiment qu'on va essayer de venir
décortiqué ici à vous est prêt et bien
on y va
[Musique]
alors il ya plusieurs choses à venir
regarder parce que c'est marrant mais je
sais pas moi j'ai mille balles à mettre
sur un téléphone 1100 euros 1200 euros
la plupart des gens on se dire tiens je
vais m'acheter le dernier galaxy s 22
ultra s22 plus ou alors je vais
m'acheter le dernier iphone je connais
assez peu de monde qui vont se dire
tiens j'aime à venir m'acheter le honor
magic quatre promus c'est normal parce
que au nord revient donc ils ont tout à
montrer ils ont tout à dormir tout à
prouver et on prend même d'autres très
gros du marché qui performent énormément
pas séparer de xiaomi par exemple je
connais assez peu de personnes qui vise
à bâtir je vais acheter le plus gros
smartphone de chez nous il ya plus de
1000 aux pressions cool mais je vais pas
le faire donc dans la tête des gens il
reste toujours cette idée de valeur
refuge de smartphones très haut de gamme
quand on a beaucoup d'argent on va là ça
nous rassure parce que c'est connu
reconnu donc là il ya du travail à un
vrai travail de fond pour faire
connaître reconnaître est allé plus loin
au niveau de la marque et donc on a
regardé si au final ça vaut le coup pas
peu dire acheter ce truc là là cette
petite bête là le nord magic 4 propre à
ce que je vous ai déjà présenté fait de
superbes promesses mais ce qu il les
tient c'est ça la vraie question alors
regardez donc le magic quatre procès
cette petite bête cette petite bête elle
est cool elle est jolie elle est jolie
pourquoi pour plusieurs choses bon déjà
le design est sympa le design est un peu
différent il prend au taquet les traces
de doigts énormément après parce que je
vais vous recommander c'est quand même
devenir le protéger et un deuxième truc
à savoir sur ce smartphone c'est qu'il
chauffe il chauffe assez vite lorsque
vous allez venir chercher de la
performance derrière c'est un dragon 8
de première génération il va venir
tartiner on a de la performance ça
marche bien pas de problème et on peut
se rassurer parce qu'on va venir mettre
une coque de protection l'arrière de ce
smartphone ça veut dire que le côté show
vous n'avez pas le sentir vous n'allez
pas être embêté sap à venir faire fondre
votre coque de protection c'est une
toute petite chaleur normale au niveau
d'un smartphone donc là-dessus il n'y a
pas de souci au niveau design je trouve
bien je trouve qu'à lille est sympa il
un peu différent avec ce gros module
photo don qui fonctionne et moi il m'a
séduit c'est vrai qu'il m'a séduit de ce
côté là donc j'ai pas de soucis non plus
ce qui m'a aussi séduit c'est la prise
en main alors je sois un poil large un
poil je suis pas complètement le tour
mais quasiment est-ce que c'est
dérangeant ça ne l'est pas pour moi ça
pose pas de problème donc là dessus
aussi ça fonctionnera via nos trucs sais
pas si vous l'avez vu regardez l'europe
il est verrouillé il va se mettre un peu
face à moi et il se déverrouille ça
c'est un truc qui est intéressant c'est
un peu comme freaks heidi d'apple c'est
à dire qu'en fait vous avez une caméra
3d à l'avant qui va venir reconnaître
votre visage c'est pas juste une
reconnaissance comme un élément de
dimension c'est vraiment de la trois
dimensions donc un côté qui est
rassurant là dessus qu'ils viennent
déverrouiller rapidement si vous voulez
pas faire ça et bien il ya également un
capteur d'empreintes digitales qui route
bien qu'ils réactif donc on voit qu'on a
des éléments technologiques et 7 truc
qui est intéressant c'est à dire que
quand on est un outsider on doit mettre
de la techno de la techno de la techno
d'avenir montrer les muscles et montrer
qu'on a beaucoup de techno et ici on a
beaucoup de techno première techno qui
m'intéresse c'est certain qu'on va me
regarder en premier c'est l'écran ce
smartphone il est vraiment super beau on
est sur un très bel écran amoled nahd et
contraste infini on a les noirs profonds
pour ces de la monnaie c'est un peu de
l'histoire marketeux et lorsqu'on y
regarder une vidéo à des gens sains moi
je vais vous mettre une petite vidéo de
monsieur gros histoire de se marrer les
mecs qui monte ses vidéos bah ouais
comme ça on n'a pas de points de droit
d'auteur c'est mes vidéos alors il ya 10
à plusieurs sujets là dessus moi je
trouve que l'image allait-elle il ya un
côté un peu brillant sur l'image cicr
qui allie alors ça va être un peu
compliqué je vous en rendre compte comme
ça pour vous au travers d'une vidéo mais
moi en ayant les yeux directement dedans
je trouve que l'écran est super mais
calibre il est très beau bien maîtrisé
très très très très bel écran donc ça
c'est très très chouette donc ce avec
l'expérience là dessus au niveau du
multimédia si vous venez jouer si vous
voulez une belle qualité d'affichage
vous avez une belle qualité d'affichage
donc ça c'est cool mais ça ne s'arrête
pas là on a tout ce qu'on attend au
niveau paramètres d'un smartphone avec
une bonne expérience avec à l'écran
regardez vous allez avoir alors je
trouve que le menu est un petit peu
austère ce sont je pensais mériter un
peu de huawei l'expérience logiciel elle
est intéressante elle se rapproche un
peu de huawei avec les services google
je trouve ça un peu austère alors vous
avez plein de petits paramètres
amélioration de la vidéo qu'on peut
venir activer/désactiver real et hop
plafond va venir à l'activé vous avez le
boost de fréquence d'image up eh bien on
va venir également activé pour venir
ajouter des images dans les images c'est
intéressant on va avoir la résolution de
l'écran alors on a un écran avec une
résolution en quad hd donc ça c'est
plutôt cool pouvait venir à choisir de
venir le faire manuellement rester en
automatique laissée la résolution
intelligente laisser le téléphone sur le
boulot pour vous mais voyez on est en
quad agit donc c'est pareil ça c'est
vachement cool et on a également la
fréquence taux de rafraîchissement vous
le laissez également en automatique en
120 images par seconde on peut soit 190
160 comme on veut laisser le smartphone
gérer pour vous il saura mieux vaut il
fera de façon intelligente
intelligemment et surtout il va venir le
faire plutôt bien lorsque vous allez
commencer à manquer un petit peu de
batterie envoyée il ya pas mal de
petites choses qui sont là pour venir
augmenter l'expérience pour qu'une fois
tout dans cette idée de lahoud cider ou
doit en être un paquet et là il en met
un paquet et l'expérience est cool pour
ce que vous venez regarder un film ou
série joue à des jeux faire des choses
l'expérience est très bonne il ya un
autre point qui est intéressant
également au niveau l'expérience
multimédia il ya effectivement tout ce
qui va être visuel il ya également
l'audio qui est extrêmement important à
leur tour autant on peut venir brancher
un casque non pas filaire si on n'a pas
de prise directe regarder il y en a pas
ça n'existe pas mais vous pouvez bien le
maître sans fil en bluetooth bon comme
tous les smartphones vous me direz donc
là on n'a pas grand chose et très
différenciant mesquin terrien ce qu'on
me dit haut-parleurs stéréo là il a le
haut parleur de gauche il va être un
petit peu plus étouffée que le haut
parleur de drôle c'est à dire que le
haut parleur vous avez à droite c'est
vraiment le haut parleur principal c'est
à dire que c'est vraiment là où le son
va être le sont at respectent plus large
à gauche on a beau avoir un haut parleur
qui ressemble sensiblement celui de
droite au niveau de la grille où on dit
qu'en fait c'est pas juste le petit haut
parleur d'appel c'est pas un beau
parleur de renforts et ça situe entre
les deux on est un peu entre le haut
parleur de renforts vous allez avoir sur
le côté et qui va venir apporter un
petit truc médium sur le côté et le haut
parleur principale qu'on retrouve sur la
gauche pour autant de rapport à un son
qui sera aussi bon que ce côté là que de
l'autre côté ça va néanmoins porter en
spatialisation parce que voyez la source
arrive à peu près du même côté il ya une
vraie symétrie de chaque côté dont ça
c'est plutôt cool mais le son est un
petit peu plus étouffée j'ai bien un
petit peu plus c'est pas gagné non plus
mais légèrement on est vraiment cette
sensation de spatialisation qui est là
qui est chouette on se sent plus immergé
mais on en a un petit peu moins sur la
gauche sur la droite il faut le savoir
mais je trouve quand même que c'est cool
et parce que vous regardez aujourd'hui
même des smartphones dans le très haut
de gamme comme ça sont pas parfaits et
c'est pas souvent là on va voir le truc
de fou on redescend un peu ça devient
rapidement médium pour qu'il n'est pas
extrêmement puissant pissant j'ai connu
des smartphones qu'il est beaucoup plus
puissant ça sert à rien on s'arrache les
oreilles on va venir à faire saturer les
haut parleurs ça ne sert à rien donc
comme il est là ça ne règle donc
l'expérience très honnêtement très haut
de gamme sont très bonnes et ça c'est
aussi très très chouette on sait donc
que on a un écran qui est top on sait
donc qu'on a de l'audio qui est bon
comme je voulais dit la performance est
là vous avez une configuration avec le
ca dragon huit gènes 1 vous avez 8 giga
d'amour pourrait en vouloir un peu plus
mais on a ce qu'il faut après il ya une
techno internat au nord qui l'ont depuis
des années c'est ce qu'on appellera le
gpu turbo c'est d'un point de vue un
gros logiciels ils viennent dire
optimiser un peu l'histoire bon ok ça
fonctionne ya un gars nouveau ici à un
truc qui est intéressant c'est
l'autonomie alors je vous le dis frank
biller ce n'est pas le smartphone qui a
la meilleure autonomie ce n'est pas le
smartphone qui vous emmènera le plus
loin néanmoins ce qui est venu faire au
nord ici je mets déjà montré lorsqu'on
l'a ouvert qu on lan boxer qu'on n'a pas
eu déjà pas mal pareil ce smartphone est
bien celle qui vous a mis un très gros
blocs de chardons vous via leurs charges
est très rapidement garder c'est du 100
watts et si vous voulez pas deux blocs
de charges comme ça et que vous voulez
pas vous embêter eh bien vous prenez ce
truc là c'est un but des charges sans
fil je le pose là et c'est de l'art
charge très rapide c'est du 100 watts
également regarder ses écrits sylla noir
sur blanc max 100 watts alors attention
quand on nous parle d'un bloc de charges
en soit c'est pas du sang hwa de
constance et du son va tout début ça
redescend rapidement 81 ans white 65
watts on descend pourrait venir
économiser que ça se passe bien et pas
abîmer votre smartphone mais en fait ce
qui est intéressant est ce qui est venu
faire également au nord ici c'est de se
dire qu'avec ce bloc de charge qui est
inclus dans la boîte pas l'autre info
vient d'acheter en supplément des celui
qui inclut dans le sens watts il ya vous
rechargez très rapidement donc vous
augmenter l'expérience donc la question
l'autonomie elle disparaît donc ça c'est
rassurant et ça c'est cool aussi donc
toutes ces parties là je trouve très
bonne pour on vient vraiment aligner les
planètes sont tout cet usage l'a donc un
autre usage qui est très intéressant
derrière c'est toute la partie photo
alors la partie vidéo je voulais déjà
présenté dans une précédente vidéo
savoir si on peut venir faire
effectivement et bien des vidéos de ce
smartphone en fait nous avons fait un
truc très cool on restitue rapidement
pour je redis ça si on n'avait pas envie
de regarder mon autre vidéo mais allez
la voir parce qu'elle est super cool et
je vous mets libyen dans la description
c'est qu'en fait tu pouvais venir faire
des vidéos un petit peu standard c'est à
dire des vidéos classiques avec
différents effets tout ça mais ils ont
fait un truc au delà de ça qui est
intéressant c'est à vous pouvez filmer
dans un mode qui est spécial c'est un
mode qui est plus fait pour les
créateurs de contenu qui ont un peu
envie de s'embêter ce qu'on appellera en
logs log c'est quoi c'est l'équivalent
du rohan photo c'est flat dont votre
image elle vous parlez très délavé très
pâle et pour autant elle contient toutes
les informations de colorimétrie de
contact de couleurs que vous avez à
l'intérieur dont vous pouvez vraiment
venir travailler d'ailleurs en
post-production que c'est vachement bien
si vous voulez utiliser votre smartphone
dans ces conditions-là aller voir ma
vidéo vous verrez qu'il est très très
très bon là dedans et après vous avez un
autre mode qui a mode avec des lottes
dhelens une colorimétrie convient
appliquée par dessus vous n'allez pas
les appliquer sur votre login et
appliqué directement sur votre fichiers
natifs c'est pas parfait et c'est pas
dingue c'est un truc un peu marrant si
on a envie mais pour moi ça pas grand
chose le truc qui est vraiment
intéressant c'est le format log et ça
c'est juste hyper canon parce que vous
le prenez vous le jetez dans un final
cut pro dans un première derrière vous
venez faire une vraie édition une fois
de plus je manque tout ça dans ma vidéo
c'est très cool rien un truc est venu
faire ici au nord où là ils ont vraiment
venu de xian jh alizade c'est à dire que
vous êtes 3 capteur à l'arrière vous
avez un capteur principal de 50 méga
pixels c'est pas de grand-angle vous
avez un autre capteur c'est un ultra
grand-angle où ils ont mis également 50
méga pixels et puis vous avez ensuite on
va se dire un téléobjectif zoom
périscopique leur naissance du 64
mégapixels ok alors moi ce qui
m'interesse vachement c'est ce qu'ils
ont fait ici là parce que tout ce passe
ici ça c'est intéressant pourquoi parce
qu'en fait vous allez avoir la même
lorimer tri la même plainte d'image
entre ses deux capteurs parce qu'ils ont
développé une technologie qui s'appelle
l'ultra fusion et l'ultra fusion elle
est intéressante pourquoi ça c'est
pareil en tout qui vachement bien et
qu'on retrouve ici et pas ailleurs c'est
à dire que lorsque vous allez venir
faire une photo avec j'en sais rien moi
votre capteur principal eh bien il va
venir bosser pour récupérer hop un peu
d'image de votre ultra-grand-angle en
même temps et il va prendre ces deux
images et il va venir les fusionner pour
vous optimisez votre image qui va sortir
et le truc est génial ça vous permet
voyez sur ses rails on va surprendre des
détails ici ou ici vous donner un truc
avec un meilleur rendu donc le touquet
est un peu con comme ça mais c'est toute
cette technologie que vous avez à
l'intérieur qui font votre smartphone il
est cool il intéressant et ça c'est une
vraie belle différence et ça c'est très
chouette donc on a vraiment un combo
gagnant on le voit aujourd'hui les
smartphones dans le l'entrée de gamme et
le milieu de gamme ils vont privilégier
le grand temps fatalement l' ultra
grand-angle il met pas de tels objectifs
ça c'est plus le truc qu'on vit remettre
dans le très haut de gamme avec un zoom
périscopique où on va aller jusqu'à 1 x
100 très honnêtement de vous à moi le
froid sans il est naze ne servirait à
rien tout ce qui est très bien qui est
très beau ici c'est le foie 3.5 il est
canonissime les images sont très belles
on a de superbes rendu il est très bien
donc si vous voulez un très bel appareil
pour venir chuté avec votre grand temps
que votre ultra-grand-angle ou votre
télé en x 3,5 un peu plus mais bon on va
pas aller trop loin pas c'est vachement
bien ils ont vraiment fait un truc au
début j'avais un peu peur sur les
premières images que j'ai vues je
trouvais qu'il y avait un petit peu trop
de travail algorithmique pour venir
pousser le lan et tai je trouve que ça
faisait semblant un petit peu trop mise
à jour était fait et là ça fonctionne et
là ça marche bien et là c'est cool donc
ce soit en vidéo si vous êtes vidéaste
si vous êtes sûr qu'il toc les réseaux
et compagnie vous avez toute une pléiade
d'accessoires pour venir bosser que ce
soit en amateurs semi amateurs ou sur du
semi pro attention n'est pas un mot sur
du propre convention smartphones
aujourd'hui n'est pas encore au top là
dessus mais c'est très très bon par
rapport à se prendre sur le match et ça
c'est cool et puis bien évidemment sur
tout ce que vous avez sur la partie
photo donc toute la partie création
contenu on a de quoi s'amuser on a de
quoi se marrer donc ça c'est cool le
truc qui est un peu en dessous et qui
vous quand même savoir c'est que le
micro de cette petite bête là il est pas
dingue dont venaient utiliser un micro
extérieur ou alors utiliser directement
les petits écouteurs de honor qui
viendront améliorer le son pour entendre
votre voix plutôt qu'à voir ça en face
d'eux ou c'est du point de détail mais
c'est intéressant donc il ya vraiment un
truc qui est très cool un très très beau
travail qui venait faire au nord ici
aussi et puis il ya d'autres choses qui
sont venus mettre dans toute cette
techno parce qu'une fois de plus il faut
mettre de la techno un peu pour de la
technologie pour montrer les fait chier
omis attention avec des fiches
techniques ultra boustead si vous
regardez le discours de marketing de
chez loomis et les steaks respecte les
spectres les specs les specs alors que
d'autres vont faire un gros travail je
pense notamment google sur ses pixels
les usages les usages les usa jouent à
peu les usagers suis à des usages
d'autres lorsqu'ils zareph sont un peu
outsiders doivent montrer les muscles
avec les specs respecte les specs les
specs et c'est ce que fait au nord ici
là que vous avez du wifi si ça nous fait
si c'est ça peut faire un peu râler on a
de l'ue travaille bande on a dû à un
excès bien évidemment faire face à leur
tour un peu partout donc ont un
smartphone qui est très haut de gamme
très complet aujourd'hui pour 2022 donc
là-dessus il n'y a pas de mauvaises
surprises ça marche très bien en plus de
ça et comme le font toutes les marques
aujourd'hui ils ont tout cette notion
d'écosystème avec un pc que vous allez
pouvoir avoir de honor le partage
d'écran je prends je pose de transfert
je prends des appels directement ici et
je les récupère sur mon pc enfin bref le
truc et pratique le truc c'est dur à
dire ça le truc est pratique et ça
marche super bien donc à la question est
ce que au nord a réussi son magic 4 pro
est ce que c'est un smartphone sur
lequel on peut venir se positionner pour
moi la réponse est oui oui pourquoi
parce que c'est un très joli smartphones
attention attention il est cher on est à
1099 euros c'est vrai que je me pose la
question si on s'était dit que ce
smartphone écouter 999 euros ou 990
euros on se serait dit ouais c'est bien
mais ils sont pas comme les autres et
sont à moins de 1000 euros et là comme
ils sont au dessus de 1000 euros mais à
pas grand-chose s'emballe ça fait quand
même beaucoup d'argent mais quasiment 99
euros on va dire ouais mais pour le au
nord ça reste cher oui c'est toujours un
peu le côté psychologique d dupré ici
qui est super important moi je vous
assure que ce smartphone là il vaut ses
1099 euros de la même manière vous allez
vous retrouver avec un samsung galaxy s
ii ultra un peu plus cher ils ont
vraiment bossé sur la partie création de
contenu la partie divertissement la
partie performance trouve que
l'autonomie est un peu en dessous c'est
un peu dommage on a une bonne journée au
delà de ça il va falloir bien leur
charge et vous n'allez pas le pousser
une journée et demie deux jours sauf si
vous êtes vraiment light night lights
live et quand on a un truc comme ça on a
envie d'utiliser tout le temps donc bon
c'est je pense un peu un peu le point
faible je pense qu'il ya un truc qui
pourrait aussi être améliorée c'est
toute l'expérience logiciel qui pourrait
être un peu sexy fier je la trouve
efficace mais je trouve qu'elle manque
un peu de sexy elle manque un peu de
superbes alors que le smartphone je
trouve très sexy mais je trouve que
l'expérience logiciel est un petit peu
en dessous donc voilà il ya ces quelques
petits points mais au-delà de ça et si
ces choses là ne vous dérange pas sachez
qu intérieure vous avez quand même plein
de choses que vous pouvez venir
paramétrer facilement le smartphone est
plutôt joli il est quand même un peu
grand si vous aimez les petits
smartphones n'étaient pas faits pour où
il fait ses 200 quelques grains bon
voilà pour moi ça me pose pas de
problème j'utilise un smartphone très
gros et très lourd au quotidien donc
celui-là je peux vous assurer que il ne
dérange pas donc c'est vraiment ce que
je voulais dire partager avec vous c'est
un peu la conclusion finale sur ce
produit là et c'est intéressant on
arrêtera de parler voyez des eaux nord
qui revient qu est ce qui vous guette la
gagne après ce bon on va pas sympa autre
chose mais c'est vraiment le grand come
back avec une gamme complète au nord
magic 4 prawna le magic 4 lite on encore
le honor 50 qui est là on a le x7 et le
x8 dont je vous ai parlé il y en
ad'autres sia le pliant qu'on a vus mais
qui n'est pas encore en france bref y'a
plein de choses j'ai les accessoires il
ya également des pc d'envoyer au nord
c'est une marque sur laquelle il faut
compter en 2022 je pense qu'en 2023 ils
vont continuer à mettre la purée le
bouzin en avant pour que ça marche de
plus en plus donc voilà je compte sur
vous pour dire ce que vous en pensez
pour moi si vous voulez y aller si vous
avez et 1099 euros pour y aller les yeux
fermés ça très joli smartphone en plus
avec un indice de réparer vite et de 8
sur 10 plutôt rassurant jolie marque
sérieuse voilà dites moi ce que vous en
pensez en bas en commentaire nous on se
retrouve très vite pour continuer à
parler tech et de plein de choses et
bien évidemment due aux normes mais pas
tout de suite plus tard dans le reste de
l'année je vous embrasse pour les soins
de bouillasse habite chaos
[Musique]